spider-man far from home has finally
arrived and it's a lot to take in if
you're wondering what those post-credit
scenes mean for Peter Parker and the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
don't worry we've got the answers you
need and if you're Peter tingle is
tingling that's because there are
spoilers ahead
bad luck is a hallmark of spider-man
stories this is particularly true in
spider-man far from home where bad luck
follows him home and into the mid credit
scene after the credits roll his date
with MJ is interrupted by a news
bulletin that introduces none other than
J jonah Jameson to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe good news to fans everywhere
JJJ is played by JK Simmons reprising
his fan-favorite role from the Sam Raimi
trilogy Jameson has a video that
mysterio dr. to make it look like
Spiderman was behind the London attack
and he has no problem showing it he also
has no qualms about letting the world
know that spider-man is Peter Parker
outing the teenager to the world now in
addition to whatever supervillain he
paddles next Peter Parker will have
Jonah staring him down trying to ruin
his day and his life at every turn and
that adds a whole new level of conflict
for future films spider-man hero or
menace exclusive Daily Bugle photo
menace he was protecting that armor :
Atticus you take the pictures I'll make
up the headlines okay the introduction
of Jay jonah Jameson and the Daily Bugle
into Peter Parker's New York City is a
bold move forward for this little corner
of the MCU and many past spider-man
films Peter at least had the benefit of
being spider-man anonymously also
managing to work for the bugle as a
photographer that doesn't seem to be
something that would fly here unless
he's really good with a fake ID what
this suggests is that we're about to
enter an era during which all of New
York City is automatically suspicious of
spider-man worse it's a world in which
Peter will have to lay low and keep any
super verow exceda's it calls into
question every aspect of his life from
his membership in the Avengers to his
remaining years of high school and his
entire future he's going to have to find
a way around this and perhaps more than
any other teaser in the film's credits
this condition carries the most weight
moving forward
the mid-credits scene gives us a big
tease about the future of spider-man but
the post-credits scene in far from home
adds an even bigger hint about the
future of the MCU as fury and he'll
drive away from their London operation
Hills face changes to reveal that she's
actually the scroll Sauron fury doesn't
look shocked at all and then we see why
he shifts to and reveals that he's the
scroll known as Talos audiences last saw
these Scrolls in Captain Marvel where
they were last seen searching for a new
home now we know that Scrolls are back
on earth after the events of Captain
Marvel and they're here in a capacity
that allows them to impersonate some of
the most important people in the world
the scene doesn't tell us exactly why
they're here but it's clear that they've
agreed to impersonate Hill and fury as
they conduct some kind of mission for
Nick Fury at one point early in
spider-man far from home Fury mentioned
something about Kree sleeper cells to
he'll when it's revealed that Fury is
actually Talos that throwaway line is
revealed to have a much deeper meaning
we have no idea just yet exactly what
the scrolls are doing back on earth but
a Fury's reference to the Kree is
correct they're old enemies are also
hanging around the planets as well
Captain Marvel established an age-old
conflict between these two alien empires
which the Kree won and made the scrolls
into refugees looking for a homeland now
25 years later both civilizations could
be experiencing different circumstances
that were not fully aware of yet
Talos is mention of hidden Kree cells
while in disguised as Fury's suggests
that they could still be enemies that
adds an important context to this reveal
that future films will no doubt build on
far from homes post-credit scene
confirms for audiences that Talos
impersonated fury on earth while the
superspy lived with the rest of the
scrolls in space for at least the
duration of the film if not for longer
what the scene doesn't establish is what
happened to Maria hill given her
tendency to work in cooperation with
fury we can hazard a guess that she's
somewhere on the same ship helping with
whatever mission Fury's working on still
given that the MCU juggles plenty of
plot lines at once we can't necessarily
assume the two were still joined at the
hip perhaps she's taking her own time
off somewhere else
whatever the case her exclusion is
noteworthy well it's also noteworthy is
the film's
repeated insistence that the Avengers
just don't seem to be a thing right now
this is reinforced in the post-credits
scene in which Talos tells fury that
people kept asking him where the
Avengers were and he didn't know what to
say
obviously the roster would have changed
significantly in the wake of endgame but
numerous hero stayed on earth at the end
of that film you'd think that Sam Wilson
would have put a group together as the
new Captain America so where are the
Avengers we'll just have to see if the
next MCU film to arrive gives us any
more answers check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Spider Man far from home
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]